[Musique]
l'édition spéciale du skycos se poursuit
hobbythou à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
on va parler de cybersécurité Patrice
sur le site on va présenter nos invités
mais sur le site de l'école 2600 j'ai lu
la cybersécurité c'est pas un choix et
alors donc on présente peut-être nos
invités on a avec nous François et
nolfejas PDG d'oxybox bonjour si tu es à
Guyancourt alors votre spécialité c'est
de développer des solutions de
sauvegarde finalement quand une
entreprise ou une infrastructure se fait
attaquer et bien son activité est
sauvegardé c'est ça alors tout à fait
alors oxybox pour être précis on est
spécialiste de la sécurité de la
sauvegarde c'est à dire qu'on édite une
solution de sauvegarde sécurisée mais
également une solution qui permet de
garantir la sécurité de la sauvegarde
pour qu'elle soit exploitable après une
cyberattaque avec nous aussi Axel
Dreyfus le co-fondateur de l'école de
1600 on salue d'ailleurs Valérie de
Saint-Père absolument et
oui l'école de 1600 c'est au fond
l'école de la cybersécurité alors en
fait on a décidé de monter cette école
pour répondre à un enjeu stratégique au
niveau des filières on s'est bien au
niveau des partenaires privés que du
regalien pour pouvoir former des experts
en cybers sachant qu'il en manque à
priori à minima 35000 spécialistes en
France actuellement d'accord ah oui
35000 et on parlera tout à l'heure avec
Nicolas qui était étudiants
avec Maxime qui est en deuxième année de
l'école mais peut-être que vous
commencez par oxymox alors oxybox ça
date vous avez créé la start-up quand
alors oxybox a été créé en 2014 et en
fait on a passé quatre ans à faire que
de la R&D donc à développer le produit
et on a mis notre produit sur le marché
mi 2018 pour la première fois et on
connaît depuis une croissance supérieure
à 50% chaque année du fait de la
multiplication des cyberattaques alors
du fait on est effectivement très porté
par la multiplication des cyberattaques
et on a le cas de l'hôpital
sud-francilien qui est évidemment je
pense très présent aujourd'hui dans les
têtes et
mais on est aussi porté je dirais par
une prise de conscience générale
du fait que aujourd'hui il est
indispensable d'assurer une posture de
cybersécurité on a le positionnement
avec oxyvox de pouvoir répondre aux
besoins des plus grands mais aussi des
plus petites structures c'est à dire
qu'on est très présent dans les
territoires on est en face d'équipement
de plus de 3000 collectivités
territoriales à l'instant on parle et
c'est porté par l'actualité certes mais
c'est aussi porté par une montée en
maturité encore une fois des différents
décideurs sur les sujets technologiques
oui parce que pendant un temps on avait
l'impression que les entreprises je
disais les cyberattaques c'est pour les
autres mais il y a toujours ça il y a
toujours le côté un peu c'est un
sinistre dans la foudre ne frappe jamais
deux fois au même endroit parce qu'il
faut d'ailleurs dans le cas de la foudre
mais ce qui est encore moins vrai dans
le cas des cyberattaques puisque au
contraire une fois qu'on sait qu'une
entité qu'une entreprise est vulnérable
il y a plus de chances qu'on essaie de
repasser pour avoir un foi un deuxième
bénéfice en tant qu'attaquant
ce sont des hackers il faut quoi il
demande
comment ça se passe
économique organisation criminelle il
faut savoir que la criminalité organisée
sur Internet son chiffre d'affaires
dépasse celle aujourd'hui tu trafic du
stupéfiant au niveau mondial donc
aujourd'hui c'est quand même aujourd'hui
en terme d'extorsion aujourd'hui
d'industrie à part après on a toute la
partie espionnage industrielle qui elle
ne se voit pas aujourd'hui mais c'est
quand même majeur après aujourd'hui on
peut avoir des activistes qui vont
défendre des causes politiques et
actuellement nous sommes dans un
contexte géopolitique aujourd'hui ou la
partie renseignement aujourd'hui ils
évidente
généralement qui sont des organisations
criminelles soutenues aujourd'hui par
des des par des gouvernements on peut
citer la Corée du Nord le régime turque
iranien aujourd'hui ou chinois qui sont
excessivement réactifs dans ce domaine
Jean-François Nicolas le disait vous
votre cœur de métier si je peux dire
c'est de garde de sécuriser les données
d'une entreprise même quand elle est
attaquée c'est ça alors tout à fait
alors il faut évidemment qu'on soit
déployé avant l'attaque mais on va
permettre de redémarrer instantanément
après une cyberattaque en garantissant
que les sauvegardes soient exploitables
et puis évidemment on est en des
technologies qui vont nous permettre de
garantir un redémarrage rapide donc on
est d'une certaine manière on est un peu
la brique de base de la cybersécurité le
niveau 0 peut-être c'est à dire que
quand on a aucun équipement c'est-à-dire
qu'on part de 0 en termes de cyber on va
être attaqué être attaqué fréquemment on
est une cible facile et donc on va avoir
besoin de redémarrer très souvent et
quand on est même très équipé évidemment
on a un facteur de risque qui est
moindre on devient une cible complexe
mais même là le risque zéro il existe
jamais
en termes de cyber et donc on aura
toujours besoin d'être capable de
redémarrer oui il y a des très grandes
entreprises qui ont été attaquées qui
étaient spécialistes de la cybersécurité
qui ont été attaqués y compris récemment
et effectivement ce qui démontre que
personne n'est à l'abri est-ce que
pardon
juste une question pour Axel sur l'école
2600 ça a été et il y a un an vous avez
soufflé votre première bougie il y a une
montée en puissance réelle parce que
vous êtes crédible auprès de nombreux
acteurs importants de la cybersé a été
initié il y a plus de 8 ans suite à une
collaboration dans un laboratoire de
sécurité assez connu en France où on
travaillait sur l'émission de départ
laxi on s'était promis aujourd'hui de
monter une école de cyber avec certaines
spécificités si on prend par exemple ici
on a la Seconde Guerre mondiale si
jamais la France se formait en 40 on va
éviter de mobiliser les troupes 3 ans
après donc on voulait avoir finalement
une école en alternance pour répondre
immédiatement vous allez l'entreprise
parce que l'avantage c'est que
l'intégralité des étudiants ne paye pas
leurs études celles-ci sont aujourd'hui
par la taxe d'apprentissage collectée
par l'État reverser aux branches qui
nous financent mais ce qui me permet
aujourd'hui d'avoir des étudiants qui
sont immédiatement opérationnels c'est
comme si je devais former mobiliser pour
les livrer sur le marché 3 ans après la
bataille donc l'avantage c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je forme mes étudiants
immédiatement en termes de chiffres on a
eu à pour cette année 1392 candidats
généralement sur les profils Bac + 3
avec une compétence déjà avérée en
cybersécurité sur lequel on a pris que
8% des élèves et on a quasiment 200
étudiants sur le campus répartis sur
plus de 140 entreprises aussi bien durer
Gallia ministère des armées ministère de
l'Intérieur différence de particules
locales et aussi sur un grand nombre
d'entreprise qu'on appelle les
AVC c'est n'importe quoi
le service essentiel et de véritables
talents parce qu'il y a des génies il y
a des je pense à Maxime sur notre
plateau
alors qui vient juste d'avoir son bac à
l'âge de 16 ans mais Maxime
voilà parce que ça fait déjà un an que
vous y êtes ça fait déjà un ange je suis
arrivé en deuxième année là la rentrée
qui s'est passé hier donc avant je viens
juste d'un débutant informatique donc de
l'informatique assez générale
j'ai voulu une spécialiser en cyber et
je suis arrivé dans cette école
en fait moi une idée de la cybersécurité
c'est le fait de comprendre les choses
en fait tout ce qui nous entoure est en
train de s'informatiser de se
digitaliser donc en fait si on veut
sécuriser quelque chose il faut le
comprendre dans son ensemble donc elle
est vraiment dans toutes les couches de
l'informatique et en fait c'est d'esprit
de recherche et qui était intéressantes
de vraiment apprendre
l'informatique mais dans son entièreté
pour voir vraiment la sécuriser donc
c'est vraiment
cette large enfin ce large panel de tout
ce qu'on peut apprendre avec la
cybersécurité le cursus c'est combien 5
ans alors la formation dure trois ans
sur la partie quasiment en 2600 heures
et on le forme finalement sur une
excellence master donc
organisme certificateur par France
compétence donc à la problématique de la
prise de conscience dans la
cybersécurité mais l'autre problématique
aussi c'est le manque de compétences
d'où votre existence à l'école de 1600
François est-ce que vous vous ressentez
ce besoin ah bah de clairement ce besoin
il touche toute la filière et
effectivement enfin Axel illustré on a
on a postes à pourvoir dans l'année
quasiment en cybersécurité donc on a
vraiment besoin d'avoir ses compétences
face à nous aujourd'hui on est sur une
filière qui est relativement jeune donc
effectivement des formations de
spécialistes en cybersécurité c'était
essentiel et ça n'existait pas avant
donc on est obligé de rattraper le
retard qu'on a en la matière en sachant
déjà les filières informatiques j'irai
traditionnelles
manque elle-même également de personnel
la spécialisation cybersécurité et le
fait de pouvoir avoir des experts dans
ces catégories là et est absolument
vitales pour que la France soit
compétitive en la matière il y a un plan
cybersécurité très ambitieux qui avait
été annoncé par le président au
précédent quinquennat et pour être mis
en oeuvre tout simplement il faut qu'on
ait les ressources pour le mettre en
oeuvre et c'est un mal français
aux États-Unis dans le cadre de
l'émission de la cybergers force ça me
rencontrer le pendant américain de
l'ancien qui s'appelle le 6a les besoins
actuels en effectif sur le marché
américain ce chiffre sera un demi
million de personnes non et gloire qui
vont passer c'est intéressant la
première c'est qu'ils vont aligner les
salaires du public avec ceux du privé
pour entraîner une mobilité vers les
services fédéraux de l'État américain et
la deuxième chose c'est faciliter
l'octroi des visas donc on a rendu les
cours d'anglais obligatoirement mais je
dis ça avec beaucoup d'humour mais on
risque aussi d'avoir une fuite des
cerveaux des personnes que nous formons
en France aujourd'hui ce qu'on a déjà
constaté aujourd'hui dans la Silicon
Valley aujourd'hui une fuite aujourd'hui
qui ne peut être qu'endémique est-ce
qu'il y a une course de vitesse entre au
fond les hackers et et les gens qui
s'occupent de la cybersécurité alors oui
toujours alors parfois on a même
certains pays où la ligne de partage des
eaux départements évidemment parce que
généralement si on prend les groupes
russes généralement ils ont le droit
d'attaquer tous les cibles à l'extérieur
surtout quand elles sont recommandées
par le Gru mais par contre elles n'ont
pas droit d'attaquer les civils à
l'intérieur on ne se veulent pas entre
nous maintenant il y a toujours une
course aujourd'hui mais on a toujours
l'initiative quand on fait l'attaque
rarement quand on fait la défense il
faut savoir que 80% des métiers ou qui a
nous formons sur des métiers de défense
et il faut comprendre les psychologies
de l'attaquant sachant que le prix de la
cyberbe n'est pas que technique et c'est
en cela où je fais un appel aujourd'hui
aussi au profil féminin parce que mon
cruellement aujourd'hui d'ici et
vendeuse absolument alors vous avez
certains pourquoi aujourd'hui pourquoi
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on considère que
sur les métiers techniques alors ce sont
des bêtises aussi qui peut voir la
psychologie des attaques qui ont eu lieu
concernant uber sur ce qu'on appelle des
attaques par hdrie sociale aujourd'hui
c'est pas uniquement des attaques
techniques en tant que tel on a besoin
de de gens qui sont capables de faire ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui de l'intrusion
fine de pouvoir travailler aujourd'hui
sur la recherche en sous-solver sur les
métiers de renseignement et linguistes
aussi on a pas uniquement le mythe
aujourd'hui du hacker à capuche je pense
qu'à un moment se mites aujourd'hui nous
fait tord dans l'industrie on a besoin
de ressources féminins et certains pays
aujourd'hui le rendre possible grâce au
service militaire c'est le dial Israël
ou 50% des cyber-combattants sont des
femmes et peut-être qu'en France on
avait un retour au service militaire
obligatoire pour les femmes ce qui
n'était pas le cas peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui on pourrait peut-être
faciliter aujourd'hui la présence de
femmes dans l'industrie en tout cas
maxime a pas pas de problème à se faire
pour son emploi futur
entre l'école et toute la France il y a
beaucoup d'alternants qui sont en dehors
de la région parisienne qui peuvent
travailler dans toute la France même si
l'école est implanté à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines oui
effectivement juste à côté de la
médiathèque et pour prendre un autre
exemple l'autre jour vous avez reçu un
commandant de la Marine nationale lors
de votre soirée et il y a des étudiants
de l'école de 1600 qui sont appelés à
être en alternance à Toulon et on a vu
des témoignages de quelques
sur TV 78 exactement
à vous des grands des moyennes mais
est-ce qu'il y a pas un plus gros effort
à faire aujourd'hui sur les PME ou sur
les TPE alors absolument il y a un gros
effort à faire sur les TPE les PME et
les collectivités territoriales en
France connectivité absolument en France
on a la particularité d'avoir quand même
36000 communes à peu près 46 000
établissements publics au total qui sont
des entités qui ont des budgets limités
mais qui ont des besoins qui sont bien
réels et qui sont souvent les premières
cibles des attaquants
dont certaines d'ailleurs pardon mais tu
parlais tout à l'heure de d'opérateurs
d'importance vitales dont certaines
d'ailleurs bien qu'elle soit des toutes
petites collectivités territoriales sont
des opérateurs d'importance vitale parce
qu'elles gèrent la distribution des eaux
par exemple et donc toutes ces toutes
ces entités là ont un besoin en
cybersécurité qui est en fin de compte
est assez mal adressé aujourd'hui
puisque la priorité aujourd'hui de
l'écosystème et du marché à être assez
concentré sur les plus grandes
entreprises qui avaient des besoins bien
identifiés qui ont des rssis qui ont des
postures qui sont matures les plus
petites entités bien souvent il n'y a
pas de RSSI donc il y a pas de
responsable de la sécurité des systèmes
d'information et donc mécaniquement
elles doivent un petit peu se
débrouiller par elles-mêmes pour
s'équiper et c'est là qu'on travaille on
travaille en lien avec cyber
malveillance.gouv.fr on travaille en
lien également avec la gendarmerie
nationale pour voir porter en fin de
compte la notion de cyber résilience des
territoires un territoire c'est
évidemment des collectivités
territoriales mais c'est aussi des TPE
PME qui représente de l'emploi à
proximité qui sont tissus économiques de
proximité qui sont particulièrement
fragiles et donc qui ont
particulièrement besoin d'être protégés
aujourd'hui merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau édition spéciale du skyeco et je
retourne cette phrase je le trouve très
très parlante la cybersécurité ça
dépasse un choix absolument
c'est sur votre site absolument on va
continuer à parler merci et bien
d'innovation avec le LNE le Laboratoire
national de métrologie et d'essai
exactement
[Musique]